let's try um
let's try izzy from philadelphia izzy
you're on the air
izzy i don't yes how are you um
so all right there's two things
that i could talk about all right i
don't know which one so i'm gonna ask
you
pick the most interesting one all right
so one of the so my
all right so i'm going to talk about um
the direction
of the democratic party and one thing
that just frustrates me about them
please all right so
one thing i've noticed is that
republicans know how to play
power politics they know how to be
corrupt they know how to get their way
they know how to go on fox news and
bend people like even if i go on fox
news it takes me a
second to step back and realize how
crazy it is um
so i wish the democrats would do
something like that but not as corrupt
like if they knew how to be better at
getting their message out yeah
um i would go even further izzy i think
you're absolutely right but i would go
even further
as i've said before um we
can't stoop to their level and start
committing crimes overt corruption
uh we we can't become trump right but
when we have the opportunity to ram
through a supreme court pick
we've just got to do it no matter what
i'm not saying commit crimes
don't assassinate people don't you know
but
the republicans at any opportunity
they will block supreme court picks from
democrats at any opportunity they will
ram through supreme court picks that
they have
any opportunity democrats have to do the
same
has to it just has to be done it has to
be done and i
completely sympathize with your
frustration that uh the left seems
either unable or unwilling
to just do this stuff because listen
playing nice with them doesn't make them
behave any better next time mcconnell
just said
they would try to block a 2024 biden uh
supreme court pick
they will do it again so i totally agree
with you
yeah um what was i gonna say
um yeah it's just they just seem to be
very
you know scared of themselves scared to
do much it seems like no it's
interesting because you know the
obviously the democratic party is more
progressive yet
in terms of the way politics is done the
republicans have changed more since say
like 1980 they have changed more i think
you're right
like 1980 politics of goethe like policy
good faith
so it's so that's kind of more like
old-fashioned
so i agree and so i agree with michelle
obama when she said when they go low we
go
high in some cases but we've got to
start taking these opportunities because
um the the the country is worse off
because democrats don't
exactly and yeah one thing um obama said
in his book is that
you know politics is a business so i
wish
democrats would see it a little more as
such for as long as it remains a
business at least democrats need to see
it that way
izzy thank you for the call thank you
david
all right izzy from philly making a very
good point i have to tell you making a
very good point
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries from the world's best
filmmakers
so yes there are some documentaries on
netflix hulu amazon but
none of those streaming services give
you anything close to the selection
of what you get on curiosity stream they
have
all the newest and most critically
acclaimed documentary titles
i'm always finding amazing stuff that i
can't find
anywhere else i just actually watched
engineering the future and just super
interesting about
we really may be on the precipice here
of a total paradigm shift in terms of
what human engineering can do
and they're always adding new stuff on
curiosity stream they have documentaries
on every topic imaginable i can watch
on every device i own and the best part
is that when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman my audience gets twenty five
percent off that makes it fifteen
dollars for the entire year
that is not a lot of money for the
amount of enjoyment
that i know you will get from
curiositystream and the link
is right underneath this video